estrogen Rafi has a long history with
the redwood trees we photograph 300 foot
tall 1500 year old tree that survived
being cut it's the scientists that study
these trees this their favorite tree
it's the most complex architectural tree
on earth is known but photographing it
is nearly impossible
there's been a lot of time figuring out
how to make this picture and ultimately
we ended up raising cameras up into the
canopy
we made it mechanized we put three
cameras on a dolly there's a gyroscope
drop it slowly down and also we're
making photographing so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna build a tree
out of lots of pictures
you